This is our handpick guide,
for your weekend, and it's National Cookie Day.
So we're cooking it off with cookies.
No, that doesn't make sense, but you know what I mean.
Okay, to eat, try Good Vibes Cookie Company.
It's a little piece of art designed for your mouth,
made by an artist in California.
And each cookie is inspired by crystals,
and they make a great gift.
So you can give someone a Rose quartz cookie
for love and harmony,
or a tiger's eye cookie for inspiration.
And great news,
no actual crystals were harmed in the making of these
cookies.
And no one has to break a tooth.
It's also on our small business gift guide,
actually this company.
Plus, we're bringing Jodi, the owner of
Good Vibes Cooking Company on the show next week, Jodi.
And we'll learn even more about these (indistinct)
designed beautiful cookies.
A lot of my girlfriends are calling me about these
and being like,
"I think these are really cool."
And you know what I have to say, Jodi,
you did something different and that is hard to do.
Okay, next.
To read.
(audience applauds)
"Little Weirds"
I sat down with this hilarious writer, Jenny slate,
and I gushed about her.
And I have to tell you, I read a lot of books for this show,
which keeps my mind very sharp.
And this one was like,
being inside of a casserole full of rose petals and,
uniqueness.
And I highly recommend this story.
Nice things to do for tipping yourself toward gentleness
and simple joy, it's on page 90.
I started with that and,
it was my entry point.
This is a phenomenal book.
To watch.
"The Undoing" on HBO.
Now I know everyone's already into this,
but we're not late to the party.
The season finale literally just came out and,
this show is so good.
It is David Kelly who does Big Little Lies.
all the way back to, Oh my God, he's done everything.
He's like the King of television,
married to Michelle Pfeiffer, by the way.
And Nicole Kidman and Hugh Grant are,
some of the best work I've ever gotten to see Hugh Grant do.
And I was lucky enough to be in a movie with him
called "Music and Lyrics"
And he is bringing his A game.
I don't really see him like this very often.
It is so striking.
The performances are extraordinary.
And if you're ever feeling bad about your life,
watch the show, it'll make you feel better.
It's also just so good, it's scary and creepy.
And like.
"The Undoing"
you'll be undone.
To download, Scrabble Go.
I am full on upset.
Oh yeah, by the way,
I'm playing like nine games simultaneously,
with Amber, Robin, Britt, Tom, like you name it.
I'm in.
I love this app.
I love playing Scrabble and this just makes it so easy
and fun.
And I have to say during COVID,
this is a great way to feel connected with people.
It is, we need this,
and it keeps your mind sharp, and it keeps you connected.
And it's just fun.
So, I won the game with Tom Green last time,
but I I don't know if I'm gonna win this one.
I got crappy letters.
And finally a recommendation from Drew's Little Yellow Book.
It's my collection of favorite products,
all available on our website.
So to buy, CVS Menuca Honey Bandages.
I'm telling ya, these are a game changer.
So you know where that little white patches normally,
that's just not the sticky part, that goes on the wound.
Well, in this, it's a patch of Menuca Honey.
And when you take the bandage off,
you will see your wound is actually much more healed,
far quicker.
I'm telling you, you will not go back to another brand.
So, check out the Menuca Honey Bandages.
They are a real game changer made by CVS.
So, you can check out all these entries and more
in the Little Yellow Book.
That was the Weekender, go have a good one.
(upbeat music)